in a surprise visit President Putin
drove himself through Russian occupied
Mario pulse Saturday inspecting newly
built facilities in what's believed to
be his closest tour to the front lines
of this war he started
Russia's military bombed seized then
annexed the Ukrainian Port City last May
damaging or destroying nearly all of its
buildings
Putin is a criminal returning to the
scene of the crime said Mario pulse
exiled mayor the international criminal
court agrees it issued a warrant for
Putin's arrest for the deportation and
Abduction of children from Ukraine to
Russia those accusations did little to
dissuade today's visit by China's
president
Xi Jinping saying his trip to Moscow is
a journey of friendship cooperation and
peace